backstreet boy aj mclean made it
official
he's the one headed to the ballroom
[Applause]
[Music]
how excited are you to be on dancing
with the stars i am
very very excited i have wanted to do
the show for
quite some time the 42 year old is
taking the competition
seriously he recently underwent a
dramatic body transformation
finally starting to see proper
definition
how much weight have you lost i've lost
about 15 pounds
grain free gluten-free sugar-free
i said i want whoever trains ryan
reynolds like that's my man crush
sure enough i was able to find
his exact trainer and my dad went back
again
aj follows in the footsteps of his boy
band brother nick carter
do you have any advice just don't get
voted off the first night
what do your kids think about you doing
the show my girls
are ecstatic um both my both my
munchkins
are dancers i know you know just from
talking to my partner
it's gonna be like my world upside down
who is that partner i cannot say who
that partner is yet
i spoke with veteran pro cheryl burke
based on her clues
could she and aj be a match
your partner associated with anyone
who's ever been on the show
yes work related absolutely has he
danced in any way before yes
recreate your your face for me when you
saw him for the first time
[Music]
cheryl just launched a new line of
sparkly face masks
you've even named them after dances
right yes you've got the mirror ball
if you had to you had to all sequins
people
they'll fit in well since new boss tyra
banks is all about style
she mentioned something about like
having her sports illustrated
photographer there i don't know when
these promo shoots are happening but i
am
so excited she wants to bring like
fashion to ballroom in a way
and i'm like as long as i can cha cha
and feel good in it then i'm down for
[Music]
whatever